welcome to this video playing a lotus
eater lotuseater this is some slow iniya
right if I'm seeing this correct yeah
right it's a soap close but you can see
that you can see the the trigger of
mountain if you if you know that that it
is there you can see it on the fly kia
the three peaks of the the trigger okay
um this laughs was Quincy to imply queen
bee six that's funny so after the
capture you intend to take with the
night we had
now he's thinking but that's funny
trying to make a gambit out of it Bishop
g4 yeah I knew it it's that's maybe not
totally wacky night taking it gifts
gives him really some some some
development yeah but okay I need to take
and now I don't want to I don't want to
play passively rather return the porn
for for a good development takes on f3 I
take with the porn 94 Queen a4tech just
playing for own for my own development
check okay Bishop b5 here and then
Bishop is free m4 very nice advantage in
development be sure two three or maybe
no no this is okay
well he gets me gets castled okay but
now there's the pointer here vitac here
jack he needs to take with the pawn
that's nice there's some way to prevent
castling him
hmm check HERE 92 intending look see one
maybe okay just keep it simple this is
always slightly better because of the c6
pawn
hmm yeah should I play queer maybe this
is the easiest and now pawn takes or
queen take them contact I can't do
politics strating straightening out the
structure yeah I was briefly thinking
maybe trick with the Queen as the pony
for can also be a be a targeted that's
hard to see right here yeah this was a
good movement I should have played Roxy
to now then worked for yeah the target
as mentioned okay so i must be alert
e-m-f to
that's unfortunately no advantage at all
it's useful anyway I guess oh no a foxy
five I mean had this anyway but it sets
even with the temple now and this is
also blocking the path to f2 this is why
I went a three before in the first place
and he's got light squared weaknesses
now maybe queen bee three f 3 f 5 this
is this type of plan
okay if I go queen bee three he might
have 85 be a queen Hanks rook takes on F
then then f2 as the the issue okay but I
have Quincy 3005 Quincy three
intermediate move ok o Queen III I don't
know what's better but yeah Quincy three
I guess the the best young
if it goes to a five-year rookie rook
takes e4 looks like I know you're in a
pin buddy Quincy too I don't have F 3
unfortunately but rookie one is good
enough away this is also possible okay I
really overlook this but maybe I can
just win win c6 would be quite okay as
well
hmm I wanted to play wookie five but
that's not really convincing hmm time
warning
yeah but it is not bad yeah look Queen
takes rook air-five is still very strong
as it is always checks check
and gathered and simplest covering the
diagonal and threatening b5 rookie 7 is
also not possible
check nice in this awkward pin
check check check check check I thought
the crew con you for would be nice but
it didn't didn't help much check okay
let's get up let's get rid of the let's
get rid of the queen seon Oh black
resigns yeah yeah I didn't I didn't get
that most are this this very very nice
position maybe around here I have some
some ways to improve the outlook c5 is
maybe simpler but this looks very good
maybe maybe this wasn't great Queen c3
is strong oh this is very strong and
then take it next to that he he has no
way to to play something like that this
is a very funny funny double attack now
and this this was keeping a big
advantage but we can take Quincy 10 this
probably would have saved him check now
this would have saved him and can't hear
what is much better again yeah okay I
guess judging from the course of the
game this was an okay result thanks for
watching